but what is womanhood to you though like  what is womanhood jess like what is it  i'm actually so surprised that the three  of you actually struggled to answer that  question like straight off the bat you  know what it is you know what it is i'm  still young i'm 18. okay cool fine you  can all come for me i'm a baby  but like i've never been able to answer  that question  do you know what i think and please  excuse me if i'm wrong because you just  live it  it's just you it's just yeah you don't  even you don't think about it yeah even  think about it right  what what is me right but i think  especially now when we're talking about  all these different identities and what  people classify as what it's hard like  it's hard to know okay what does a woman  look like